plane loads of weapons from the us uk
and other nato members were sent to
ukraine in the weeks before the war
broke out a response to russia's
military buildup along the country's
border
and after russia launched its violent
invasion on february 24th
though shipments not only got bigger but
they started coming in from more and
more countries those countries who
had never supplied us with weapons are
now doing so here's how some of the
western weapons being used by ukrainian
forces work and why they're so valuable
on the battlefield
hundreds of american javelins have been
sent to ukraine over the past few weeks
known as tank killers javelins are
particularly useful in urban combat
because they're portable
they weigh about 50 pounds and they can
be fired from a gunner's shoulder they
have a range of 65 to 4 000 meters in
most operational conditions in other
words they can hit a target nearly two
and a half miles away
and javelin missiles have infrared
seekers which allow them to make
adjustments in the air in order to hit a
moving target
javelins have two modes of fire straight
on or top attack
when shooting in top attack the missile
fires in an arc to hit the top of a
target
that's particularly important for
ukrainian forces trying to defeat
russian tanks because the top of a tank
is where it's most vulnerable
furthermore javelins are considered fire
and forget weapons the gunner doesn't
have to guide the missile to the target
and can immediately seek cover or shoot
at something else
ukrainians are also destroying russian
tanks and other targets with thousands
of n-laws sent by the uk n-law stands
for new generation light anti-tank
weapon similar to javelins they're
portable and can be fired from the
shoulder in both direct and top attack
mode
but there are some key differences at 27
pounds an n-law is almost half the
weight of a javelin and its range is
much shorter 20 to 800 meters
and the weapon uses what's called
predicted line of sight meaning the
missile cannot make adjustments in the
air
even though it can't fire as far as the
javelin experts say that that short end
of the short range can be especially
useful in urban combat settings and they
say that n-laws are going to get more
and more important as russian forces
close in on ukrainian cities
[Music]
then there are american stingers which
can shoot down low-flying airplanes
helicopters and even drones
stingers weigh 35 pounds so they're also
portable their range is classified and
stingers use an infrared seeker to lock
onto flying targets allowing them to
adjust their flight path mid-air
stingers are considered to be highly
accurate
and so far experts say that they've
helped ukraine prevent russia from
dominating the airspace
that's important because as long as the
airspace is contested russia can't just
bomb that will or freely fly troops and
equipment around the battlefield
and then there are turkish drones known
as tb2s which ukraine initially received
in 2019. the ukrainian air force says
the drones are now being used to conduct
surveillance and strike russian assets
each drone can carry four laser-guided
munitions according to the company that
makes them the drone can stay in the air
for 27 hours and it can be flown by a
remote pilot as far as 185 miles away
because the drones can hover for such a
long time experts say that they help
ukrainian forces view the battlefield
and identify high-value targets
still experts say russia maintains a
strong advantage in manpower air power
and sophisticated weaponry
and that's why ukrainian president
volodimerzelinski has been appealing for
much more than anti-tank and
anti-aircraft weapons
if you found this video informative
subscribe to the channel for more
stories like this i'll see you next time
[Music]
you